[Applaudissements]
dans la première de jean michel maire
on a une casserole de gérard louvin
honda gilles verdez avec sa meilleure
intervention sur le plateau une aporie
dubosc 1g doré de voir la casserole de
mon pote jean mi janvier dans laquelle
va être merveilleux regarder on a trouvé
la première de jean michel maire dans
touche pas à mon poste
déjà à l'époque vous êtes les chauds
comme la braise c'était le 1er avril
2010 et en fait vous n'avez pas changé
dans la tête dans la tête
pour les amoureux l'émission qui n'ont
pas suivi à présent gagnent un voyage
mais malheureusement le couple s'est
brisé avant qu'ils partent d'un mois le
temps de mettre les pieds dans l'avion
s'est brisé et les moi aussi je suis
line donc moi je prends ça mais vous
êtes surtout j'aime non je crois pas
mais celui-ci sur moundir hall côté jean
michel merle merci jean michel mr
applaudissements pour lui
[Applaudissements]